what do you got for me today bro
um look um
i've been watching your show for a very
long time i've got your book um and
i just wanted to say that
i've been living with my girl for almost
five years now
and when i first met her i had a beard
okay and i had my own place
and i had my own business i had
everything going for me
and things changed
i was renting at the time and
she was going through
a breakup and everything and
and so
she started dating you when she was
still living with another guy no he
moved out
okay so she was breaking up with them
and then she started dating you yeah so
she's a serial monogamist
anyways look
she touched my pee pee she touched your
pee and you liked that of course and
that's what happened and the sex was
amazing the sex was just ridiculously
amazing and
i fell for it
and i'm still here
and
now i'm in her frame this is her place
and
i've been struggling to
get on my feet now and
i'm trying to get back to a certain
level now and um are you guys still
together
yeah yeah okay well just like fair
warning dude she's probably gonna see
this video somebody's gonna come across
it and show it to her so what you're
about to tell me is
going to end up being problematic for
you
well look it's it's not about that look
it's it's about the fact that
um look i love her
i i deeply care for her and i want to
i want to excel with her because
i
i i care about her a lot
and
i i'm trying to
get to a point where it's like i'm the
leader i am the man of the place this is
not just your place this is my place as
well and
i'm trying to get you been with her for
how long
five years so what you're talking about
is regaining the frame of the
relationship and having her look up to
you as the alpha male 1 exactly exactly
and how do you do that if you've gone
through the betatization process now i
just say i've got to go that's the door
for me i've got to go
and what happens she's sucking my dick
she doesn't want me to leave
so
now that you know what the problem is
you can try to fix it i haven't seen a
lot of guys do this successfully like
once a woman
sees you as
a high value guy that she wants to be
intimate with and be in a relationship
with and you start dating and then she
starts you've read my book yeah
yeah and then and then she starts by the
way
good perfect so and then she starts
putting you through the beta tization
process which is a sequence of like a
series of paper cuts cut it's like death
by a thousand paper cuts and then it
gets to the point where it's like now
you're in her place and
i see everything's nicely organized over
the shoulders there it definitely looks
like a woman's kitchen oh yeah there's
cats here too
cats too all right so you know like
you've gone through all those processes
and now you're in her frame in her house
you know letting her decorate everything
her cats are [ __ ] everywhere there's
hair and everything you wake up in the
morning there's a cat [ __ ] about your
face
yeah
so
okay so let's stop on that for a minute
so if the cat vomits on the floor who
gets that
[Music]
is that you raising your hand say that
you do that's right you don't do that
anymore i i do the vomit part but she
takes the [ __ ] out of the cat litter you
don't do anything with any of that now
dude i'm alpha males do not pick up cat
vomit
i am so over it look my point is that i
am basically moving towards
being more of an alpha and i'm telling
her not if you're picking up cat vomit
it's that's you know what that's your
your cat puked on the floor i'm not
dealing with that that's your problem
it's not my problem but i have to walk
around it walk around talking about the
whole you're talking about the whole
[ __ ] problem about you see [ __ ] you walk
around it don't examine it right
and
because i'm living here i have to look i
gotta say look
what are you gonna do about that oh
the deal is you do that and i do this
it's
why is she
setting the terms of the living
arrangement not you
that's what frame is right because rich
this is her place this is her this is
her castle okay
castle does she does she own it like did
she buy it or she's drinking it i helped
to
buy this place i actually helped her i
worked for two years making sure that
she locks his place in got it so so she
she bought it you pay rent there or do
you pay half the mortgage i i give her i
give her
a certain amount every fortnight making
sure that there's food in the fridge i
do the shopping i do a lot of stuff for
her okay so where do you live
melbourne in holborn australia okay
what's um what is a family law state
when it comes to um
the matrimonial home because technically
you guys are probably common law at this
point like i would imagine that you own
half of that
well
that's the thing i don't want it
i don't want you made up you may not
want it but what you want is your
independence and you want her to look up
at you and see you as the best option
and you want to feel like the alpha in
the relationship right you want her to
be in your frame
yes how how can she be in your face see
a woman can only enter a man's frame
when she sees him as the best
hypergamous option to her and if she
sees you as the beta male living in her
house picking up her cat vomit and
insert whatever other things that you
happen to do that have you know uh
basically you know can connect to the
dots through the benetization process
you can't change her view of you until
you change those things right so it's
like
you now have to lean into your inner
[ __ ] and become something that she's
going to tell you that she hates she's
gonna say you've changed alex you're not
the guy that you know i thought you were
but you know what you you going back to
the [ __ ] guy is exactly the guy that
she liked when she met you he's exactly
say that she's not gonna admit it he's
he he also happens to be the exact same
guy that she would probably start dating
if you guys broke up right some guy that
would probably refuse to live with her
especially if he's red-pilled as [ __ ]
too right not want to deal with cat
vomit right yeah or any of that nonsense
but here you are the nice guy that's
gone through the betatization process
and you're trying to unfuck yourself and
it's like she's gonna protest dude she's
not gonna like when you say i'm not
picking up the cat vomit
i don't do cat vomit
every time i walk out the door i'm at
the door she stands at the door and say
where are you going
like when we have our fights i'm gonna
be where i'm at
well what time are you gonna be back
i'll be back when i get back oh dude you
don't own me
it's it's it's pretty bad but look okay
but that's that's the thing because you
let it get bad right like you have to
put your foot down well where you think
you're going i'm gonna be where i'm at
[ __ ]
oh oh my god how could you talk to me
like that
just take your [ __ ] gym bag go to the
gym go to your friend's house go away
for a couple of days
let her [ __ ] you know marinate on it
right and she's on the phone saying
where are you when you're about time
you're coming back your phone is off
your phone is off you don't answer it
i've i've had to turn it off but she's
constantly calling me and making sure
okay are you coming back okay you know
what i mean alex you're asking for my
help i'm telling you what to do and
you're refusing to listen to me that's
an [ __ ]
okay an [ __ ] is somebody that asks
for somebody's advice and then they do
nothing with it they just make up
excuses complicate life justify why well
i can't do any of these things rich
because i can't even leave my own place
and i'm a prisoner here because i'm
living under her thumb because it's her
place and i did all these things to help
her get it sort of thing
well
to be honest with you dude
you have two choices you can try to
re-engineer this to try to unfuck this
entire vortex that you've created for
yourself or you can leave and start
fresh with somebody new and not let this
happen again
it's it's it's like again you know the
theme of the show tonight is complexity
and simplicity and again you know the
whole oh comes razor the simplest
explanation is usually the correct one
okay the simplest explanation here the
easiest thing for you to do is just to
end this relationship and say [ __ ] it
i'm out this relationship does not serve
me i'm not gonna have somebody question
me when i walk out the door where am i
going every or side eyeing me or asking
me why i'm not picking up cat vomit
it's not my [ __ ] cat i hate cats [ __ ]
the cat
right it's i always i always say what
are the cats before
nothing what use do they serve you
all right right but i mean like you let
this happen you know you moved into her
house you allowed that whole cat
situation to move on you let her stand
at the door saying where do you think
you're going right this is a lot of
stuff that you cannot
it's i'm not going to say that you can't
do it
there's going to be a lot of people out
there that'll sell you a [ __ ] bag of
lies telling you that you can do it if
you follow these
steps and
you know watch
17 hours of [ __ ] video following all
this horse [ __ ] i'm going to tell you
right now the simplest answer all is to
say [ __ ] it i'm out
yeah wow
all right
all right
all right man um thanks for your time
rich i really appreciate it okay
marinate on that for a bit thanks bro
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you